reduce alejandra millionaire from the
national university of mexico
and
thank you so
today i will talk about more like hard
work and little results because we're
still building these resources
um
so yeah and this goes a bit more into
the
stubbornly small data sets so we are not
really
in the big
sets so you know patient registries are
very valuable a lot of you use them
through the
uk biobank
they all of us initiative uh here in the
states and there's also like big
resources like the twin registry in
australia
and you know how useful they are these
are organized systems that have all the
data stored
that have recontact so you can see what
happened to these people after years so
you can build longitudinal studies and
then have genomic information
that is accessible so but there is an
issue with these resources and this
diversity so most of the um
genomic resources that we use they
basically are built using
european ancestry descent samples so
people that live in the global north and
there's some representation of
asian populations and the african
population that have also have
quite an effort but for example latin
america or what's sometimes labeled as
hispanic populations well we are poorly
represented with like less than two
percent of the samples in
general not only in these resources but
in general in genomic data sets in
genetic studies so these are poorly
represented and furthermore
these samples are all categorized as sql
while there is a different social
demographic history along the continent
so this is an issue
so what are the efforts in mexico so how
and this is a question i have a lot how
are electronic records shaped in in our
country so 70 of the people in mexico
have are affiliated to a public or a
private health system
but we have five different systems
so 50 of the population would be of this
73 percent will be associated to the
mexican social insurance system but
there's also something called
the wealthy system that is more like
people that don't have um
officially declared jobs or people that
are like poor or that don't really have
a social security system through their
jobs
and
however
33 million of people in the country we
are 120 million people countries have no
services
and
but in general like 50 of the population
will have no way to get any health
service or not even within the private
sector because they are really far away
or they cannot pay for it
there is an official norm that was
issued in 2012
that rules how electronic records should
be settled and the issue in mexico is
that as we have five different systems
and there can also be subsets within
regions
there is no way to have one sole
electronic system and there will be
hospitals that at the end will drop them
that happens a lot at the end
the electronic system is not efficient
there is no internet connection
sometimes politicians take decisions
that are not
feasible so
you cannot set up an electronic record
in a place where you don't have
electricity so at the end they will go
back to paperwork
so this makes uh
any usage of this data
barely impossible
so how
what is the
perspective in mexico so currently
actually in 2022 uh there was a release
of these two uh major genomic resources
so there is the mexico city prospective
study that is based on samples that have
been been taken from the 90s
the
the system of recruitment is based on
two regions within mexico city so one is
called coyoacan and the other one is
tapalapa and they have a important
difference in socio-economical status
within the two regions so one is middle
upper class and the other one is low
middle class and
so what they did is that they went to
their homes and this is a
geographical based sampling so they can
only go again to the same houses but
they cannot trace back the people so if
people moved they would lose their
recontact
um so they did a medical survey with
some entrepreneur anthropometric
measurements like weight height bmi
and like glucose in blood and basic did
exome sequencing and this is 150 000
people
as i told your contact is based on
address so
in 2015 2019 they recontact people based
on these so they could only recontact
ten thousand participants because people
have moved particularly koyoka has been
heavily gentrified in the last 10 years
so people are moving out because they
can no longer pay living there
mr palapa a bit less but this
gentrification is an issue across the
whole city the major publication was
recently released and this is an effort
led mainly by oxford with the
collaboration with the national
university in mexico so all these data
is in oxford in the uk
there's another research that just also
came out the next biobank survey and
this one is led by a group in mexico in
lancavio by andres moreno and these are
samples from the national health survey
in the 2000s so these are blood samples
they have now genotypes 6000 people in
total there are 40 000 samples
and they have a general healthcare
survey unfortunately this was done with
ethics without recontact so they cannot
trace back these people and know what
happened to them
there are no autoimmune diseases
questions within this survey and it's
also an issue with this one
and there's also no information on
mental health status within this cohort
but
nonetheless these two resources are key
now in mexico to at least know the
little frequencies in the population
because that's something we didn't even
have
so
challenges recontact is an issue in our
major studies so there's no way to have
like further stages in the research or
do longitudinal research
there is an issue with centralization of
the data so one of our major resources
was built only in mexico city and only
into regions in mexico city so that
hinders
the nationwide capabilities of this
research
there is a continuous failure with the
collaboration engagement engagement with
the medical community so medical
communities in mexico are a bit more
worried about saving lives than just
taking data from patients or samples for
biobanking
so there is also an issue of lack of
trust where the scientific community and
this has been documented through the
national institutes of statistics with
the survey of perspective perception on
science and technology where people
have reported not trusting in scientists
because they know too much they have
access to a lot of money and they don't
report back their results which is not a
lie
in mexico there is still a building
sorry so in mexico people are not used
to report back to participants to at
least tell them what happened with the
data they gave or what results they got
so there is a lack of also because of
that
so
those are the challenges we had and so
we decided to start setting up three
different race trees the twin
registry a registry for parkinson and a
registry for lupus
and the idea is to have comprehensive
medical history surveys we have ethics
and consent that contemplate being
recontact
for follow-up studies we have ethics
approved for biobanking so in the three
projects we are building a dna data bank
we have mental health cognitive
assessments and lifestyle and lifestyle
surveys included and we are really
pushing this to be a nationwide
recruitment perspective so we're really
trying to get people from other regions
in the country and not only mexico city
and we are working a lot in public
engagement
through continuous communication with
participants using social media on
facebook lives and instagram and tick
tocks
um so i will talk to you about these
three surveys uh so within the mexican
registry we launched this in 2019 just
before the pandemia so we were able to
sample some participants in the twin
festival that
this community has every year
and we are collaborating with the
national multiple verse association
with a data collection through threat
cap so most of the data collection is
all purely online people can get into
our facebook pages and twitter and
just register through that
we
keep re-contacting them so they can fill
in other surveys so it's it's always a
working program in progress uh
so at the beginning we had only on-site
um sampling but well now with kobit we
really launch
social media campaigns
and also traditional media because
there's a lot of people that do not
really have access to social media
so
and we do a lot of public engagement in
the twin festivals and again with social
media campaigns like these like work
with struggle our missions are basically
how to get into the registry and login
and and do the surveys
um
so initially the surveys have been
selected to match the australian and the
united kingdom during races because we
also want to enable comparisons of data
because otherwise like we will be alone
and we have a strong focus on mental
health and cognitive development so we
do a lot of surveys on that too and we
got money from the national science
council to do
functional magnetic resonance of the
twins and this is uh up to now we have
100 pairs that have been also biomass so
we have dna samples for them
so now we currently have
more than 3 000 people register however
not all of them are our sets so we
sometimes have only one twin of the set
so still
that hampers a bit the
the analysis but now we have
almost 600 pairs uh that enable us to do
some analysis on heritability of some
traits
so
most of the age
of this of the registries is between 20
30 years which makes sense because we
are heavily based on social media
campaigns so these are the people that
access social media
and mostly we have females as well and
this is a trend you can see in a lot of
biobanks where women are more likely to
participate in research so that's a bias
we have
and um also we we now have more or less
the same number of mono-psychotic and
disease twins it's like about 1300 1200
so yeah now we are able to do some
analysis with this data
and this is just like a bite of our
progress here this is done by the
postdoc italia roman
who has been analyzing the data of
reported myopia and astigmatism in this
population and using an ace
be buried uh cholesky modeling she has
found that there is a her this is the
percentage of her heritability of
myopia and astigmatism in the mexican
population so now we're able to do some
analysis in our data set which uh just
started this is like from this year we
had we reached a number
of participants that allow us to build
uh these tests
so this is the theme like these these
projects require a lot of people devoted
to it so this is a strong collaboration
with sarah alcatel and alejandra rich
also from unam and miguel at
queensland university and these are all
the students that are
devoted to this project with the
collaboration with the national multiple
birth association
so the other project we have
is the mxpd the
mexican network for parkinson's research
and this is a project that is part of
the large pd so this is a latin american
survey of parkinson
that is
trying to collect data to build the
biggest jig was in for latin american
populations for parkinson and this is
also part of gp2 the global parkinson
genetics program
so in this case the enrollment of
participants is only through
neurologists so this is important
because in this case we really wanted
the phenotype to
well characterize well done well uh
register
but there is an issue because we have a
certain a shortage of neurologists with
a valid certification so this hampers
our capabilities to sample people in
some regions when we don't even have a
neurologist that can
do the assessment
um
so
the service i designed to match also
like large pt but also the
american research consortium of the
genetics parkinson's disease
we have funding from the michael j
j fox foundation to genotype 2500
patients and 2500 controls and we have a
finances from the american parkinson
association as well to do
deep phenotyping with cognitive decay
assessments and mental health surveys
for 500 patients and 500 controls
and up to now we have 13 clinical sites
across eight different regions on the
country so we it's not so easy to see
here
and we have also two sites for control
registries which has been really
challenging because we found out people
in mexico are not really likely to
participate as controls they need to
have an incentive and the incentive is
usually being sick
so we are trying to change that through
a lot of campaigns uh trying to help
people understand why this is important
we have three sites in mexico city so we
again see this bias but we
have been able to recruit people from
other regions like jalisco that is also
a big state in mexico
and queretaro that is where our
institution is based on
so we also do so we have certain
neurologists that are actively
registering patients
we also have sampling days calendar eyes
now in certain sites because so
particularly when the neurologists come
from a public institution they don't
really have the time to do the
assessments of the surveys and to even
do the swapping everything it's uh it's
really tagged there so we have like
sundays and saturdays where the patients
are are our
agent uh are calendarized so they can
come and we can do the assessments
ourselves but the neurologist helps us
doing some of the evaluations
we have only engagement sessions through
facebook and we also do like public
appearances through the universities
and
we also have an open campaign for
control recruitment where we try to go
to health fairs or like festivals in the
in the states so we can get some
controls in those regions
uh so up to now
we have well this is a bit old now we
have almost 200 cases and almost 200
controls so this is from may
and
my lab is mostly devoted to
understanding uh the effects of anxiety
and depression within parkinson in
mexico so this is um
led by paola reyes who's a phd student
and we have also now data for
different surveys that
are focused on anxiety and depression
and also other general mental health
issues like the ccl90r
so
we have again
in particularly in cases we have more
males because also parkinson is more
present in males but you can see there
is a bias on the controls because most
of the time is the wife that
participates at control that's the
easiest recruitment
uh but we can already already see
a trade on anxiety and depression within
the parkinson uh population will where
they will have
a higher score in these surveys
so this is
also a piece of like what we are doing
now in the lab and honestly these
results are from last month that we hit
the 100 patient then we could do some
statistics
again this is a very large effort so
this is also with sarah alejandra and
with miguel
but we were also with large pd with
ignacio mata equivalent clinic and we
have all the neurologists that are
really helping us pushing this out and
also the ngos from that are communities
of patients so that's also helping us
getting
a bit more obstruction in the
recruitment
and we have a social media team as well
here
um
and regarding the lupus project so i
don't know i probably shouldn't know but
there is a high prevalence in lupus in
diverse ancestries so actually africa is
the one with the highest prevalence but
there's also a trend in latin american
populations and also there is an issue
because for example in mexico the
official reported prevalence is 20
20 people
in 100 000
however there were some prevalence
studies within some regions by some of
the national hospitals and there was one
that
found that it was 70 over 100 000
inhabitants and also 90 in oaxaca so
we think that this number it's a bit
biased and probably is not well
calculated because there is not a
national effort or an epidemiological
survey
surveillance on these diseases
yeah sorry and it mostly affects women
so we launched this registry in may 2021
so it has been up for a year
the initial recruitment was only through
social media and it was based on
self-reported status and self-assessment
of clinical manifestations and this was
because of kovit so it was really hard
to get people into the hospital patients
completely stopped going to the doctor
that actually you can see now in the
in the outcomes and in the clinical
manifestation they have because they are
doing worst
because they haven't seen a doctor for
two years now that they are coming back
uh we see this trend and now we can
document it which helps a lot
so we started with social media
campaigns
um and with a close collaboration with
patient communities so we really work
together with these patients they also
suggest surveys because they want to
learn more about their diseases
and we now have five rheumatologists
that are
recruiting actively patients and they
really join in the last year when we
they saw
the relevance of this project and that
they could also use this data for their
own clinical research
so currently
we have more than 1500 patients here i
showed you the analysis of data for
700 patients that completed the
socioeconomic
status survey and the medical survey
so we mostly have women which reflects
uh the disease prevalence and the
presence in women
half of them have a scholar degree or
bachelor at least
and most of them have been diagnosed
within uh
they are about 36 years old
and they are mostly between 9 29 and 40
years 44 years old and
a lot of half of them are actively
working so this is a disease that also
hampers the quality of life during the
productive years of the person where
they should be working when they should
be finished school
so
most of them were diagnosed around 27
years old they take antimalarian drugs
and glucocorticoids and this is what i
was telling you about the different
systems so most of them are treated by
the national social security system but
30 percent of them are treated in the
private system and this is another
state-based social security that you get
when you work in a federal institution
so most of them they are treated in the
public system but we have an important
part of them being treated in the in the
private system uh six percent of them of
the registries were pregnant at the time
they filled in the survey and 40 of them
have
close relatives that also have lupus so
this is a
this was notable because like we know
there is
uh heritability traits uh trends but we
didn't know that it could be this high
and 24 of them have uh damage to the
kidneys
so this is currently
the region that we are covering so we
are carefully covering keretaro that is
where my institution is based and there
is this big community of lupus patient
that is called lupus mx that is based
also in keretaro but there is also
another one that is lupus morelos uh
that's also heavily represented and this
is also this affecting puebla that is
just
those are two states that are together
and you can see that we don't cover all
the regions or that are really few
patients in those regions but we also
have a map of the register
rheumatologist in the country and it
totally matches this map so if you don't
see a
high number of patients it's just
because they haven't been there no there
is no doctor to diagnose them
so
we already did some analysis on the
socioeconomic status of our patients so
most of them are what can be considered
middle class and they spend most of
their money
in food communication transport
education and health
and we already have some analysis of the
comorbidities in our patients so we
mostly see no other diseases but we do
see some hypertension and
thyroid diseases and these are the
principal critical manifestation that we
see in our patients so we see heavily
arthritis and alopecia and actually
alopecia is something that is very
worrisome for these people because well
it's how you look and that matters for
them mostly women that are losing their
hair so they are really worried about
this
so we did a
an analysis of the quality of life and
this is using us control group the twin
registry
so we can see that there is an effect on
the lupus patient on their perception of
quality of life and in particularly in
the health domain so they really
perceive that their health is lower but
it also
affects how they perceive perceive their
environment so they think their
environment is pure is pure is poor
they also perceive low physical health
low mental health and
that this affects also their social
relationships
so
uh this soon to be published as well
and within this project so uh
i'm more a genomic scientist and i like
doing rolex genomics and that's more my
lane of work so we got some money from
the national council
of science and now we are going to do a
project of knowledge specific expression
patterns in systematic lupus doing
tolerogenic and tolerogenic induction of
dendritic cells so we are getting 30
patients and 10 controls now and we are
doing this differentiation from
monocytes to polarized dendritic cells
and challenging them to see whether they
are able to stop an autoimmune response
and we are doing this because tolerant
dendritic cells are i mean
a proposal of immunotherapy for
autoimmune diseases because they could
help turn down the autoimmune response
so currently we have recruited 15
patients and six controls and we are
actually able to differentiate the cells
and this is work done by ana laura
who's a phd student in the lab and we
can already see with this 15 patients
that we
have changes in the presence of some of
the
uh
of the
sorry protein
in the membrane like cd11 or the hla and
there is a difference between the
patients and the controls
on how polarized synthetic cells are
being developed
so i want to thank all the people
involved
again here also alejandra ruiz
participates a lot because the mental
health part is very important for this
we also have a team of rheumatologists
that have joined and are helping us
recruit patients but also to design
new surveys and um i will gonna see that
this thing for part of this
and now
thanks to everything we learned we are
launching also the pediatric lupus
registry and this is going to be led by
someone else because i don't have any
more time
so this is claudia gonzaga and antalya
diazpito she's a rheumatologist at
hospital texas in monterrey and claudia
is now an assistant professor in my
institution and she's
launching the rare diseases registry
and furthermore thanks to everything we
learned now we are also part of the
chance to convert initiative and we are
going to do single cell sequencing
of immune cell types across different
countries so we are going to recruit 120
people from each of the regions we are
going to build
an atlas of latin american immune cell
diversity and we are going to work on
building regulatory networks and the
effect of variation in transcription
in transcription factor binding and
while we're bio bio-banking a lot of
these samples to be able to learn then
to do tcr
sequencing
and this is a team that has been
ensemble for this
um
so in summary we launched patient
registries in mexico and it is a
challenge but it's also very rewarding
people are really thankful this is
happening patients contact us
and well it's something that you feel
that is something useful you are doing
for your country
so people engagement is key
for these
and these resources can have great
impact in the research in the community
because they are not only for also for
me or for my group this is something
that has to be available for everyone
and this infrastructure can be used for
new registries like the one i just
showed you
um yeah this will also help increase
diversity in genomic samples but we
still have challenges so for example the
large pd data will be centralized using
a system called terra that is based in
google cloud
and it sounds super cool if you have a
way to pay for this so i'm able to
download my data so the mexican data i
can download and have it in my servers
but i cannot access the data from the
other regions of latin america unless i
have access to terra and this is
something i cannot pay for because my
university doesn't allow using credit
cards
so that's that's an issue and this is
something that is not even
talked about so this is again going to
be very advantageous for people in the
global north that have systems to do
this
but for
latin america and this is not only my
case but
the other teams see the same issue it's
hard we have a lot of issues with
corruption so the regulation on how you
can spend the money it's really tight
so you don't steal anything but you can
also don't you cannot you also pay
anything so this is going to be a
challenge that we have to find a way
to get through
so thank you for your attention
[Applause]
thank you alejandra i think we
don't have time for questions so maybe
several discussions should be moved to
coffee break and let's welcome our next
speaker aaron halperin
from optum labs and ucla